there have been rumors about A New
Nightmare on Elm Street in development
by Blum House and it all comes from this
tweet it says A Nightmare on Elm Street
recall is in development blumhouse has
been secretly working on making a recall
of the first entry of The Saga the
Revival is high priority we don't have a
date yet but we shouldn't expect it to
be so far away and the validity of this
tweet has come into question however my
friend Jimmy champagne actually recently
did a video on this where he said this
I've also heard of some stuff happening
behind the scenes from some trustworthy
people but I just wanted to get a little
bit more confirmation before I made a
video about all of this so I kind of
collected a few of the tweets and I sent
them to my friend critical Overlord
because this guy is right way more often
than he's not and he's leaked some stuff
in DMS to me about movies that I really
wouldn't make videos about that all
pretty much came true so I was like yeah
anyone's gonna know it's probably this
guy and he basically confirmed that yeah
the source who's telling us about this
stuff is pretty trustworthy like they
can be wrong like anyone else can of
course I always say take leaks with a
huge grain of salt because this stuff
can change on a dime but also he
provided me with some evidence of this
person being right in the past about the
boys spin-off show so if you're
interested in more about this movie I
highly recommend this video from Jimmy
champagne I want to hear your thoughts
and dreams about a possible New
Nightmare on Elm Street so let me know
in the comments